regardless of what happens tonight
Republicans and Democrats now agree Joe
Biden he's in deep trouble an NBC News
poll put it this way there is a five
alarm fire among Democrats as Joe
Biden's support is now bottomed out in
fact if the presidential election were
held tonight Joe would lose in an
electoral Landslide now that's according
to the brand new New York Times poll
another poll this one from Reuters shows
that Biden is near his lowest approval
ever at only 30 6% a sitting president
frankly just can't win reelection with
those kind of numbers now voters also
strongly disapprove of Biden's handling
of the economy so much for the biomics
uh that they've been pushing but you
have real inflation real difficulties at
the highest mortgage rates we've had in
decades uh we don't have secure borders
National Security concerns around the
globe American soldiers now have been
attacked 40 times in just the past few
days at base in the Middle East with
almost no response from Joe Biden at all
barely any comments meanwhile his own
party is now deeply divided over the
issue of Israel as Biden's radical
pramas base is threatening to stay home
in 2024 and last but not least Americans
are very concerned with Biden's obvious
cognitive decline it appears to be
getting worse which will only uh seem to
continue as we March towards 2024 and
one year from now as kamla would say
that's the significance of the passage
of time and according to a growing
number of Democrats are now begging
Biden to now bow out of the race
including former Democratic congressman
and Senate candidate Tim Ryan but Joe
Biden is clinging on for dear life as
always Biden values his own personal
vanity Above All Else and unfortunately
for Joe and his fellow Democrats he is
now so unpopular and incompetent that
even his own weaponized justice
department won't be able to push him
across the Finish Line this time we're
going to have more on this failed
political strategy to get Donald Trump
that's coming up hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else